turn around politics here at noon and
mail and voting could play a critical
role in the November election but the US
Postal Service is facing a major cash
crunch because of the Cova 19 pandemic
the post office told Congress it will
run out of money by September if it does
not receive 75 billion dollars in
emergency funding the president of the
American Postal Workers Union says
underfunding the postal service could
affect access to vote by mail mark Elias
is a democratic voting rights attorney
and he says that could significantly
impact our election but this is a but
this is a critical one because the fact
is if we can't have reliable mail
service then we're not going to have
reliable democracy in the fall and it's
not just Democrats concerned about
funding Republicans also say the post
office is critical to the November
election president Trump has been
critical of the postal service and
withheld funding from the cares Act they
were asking for billions of dollars he
instead issued loans demanding reforms
in return the president threatened to
withhold funding if the USPS does not
meet his demands to increase its prices